now Russia's Wagner mercenary group has
threatened to pull out of Ukraine's
embattled city of bakmud if Moscow
doesn't send more ammunition the head of
the group evgeny pagosian says that
without proper supplies his troops will
withdraw or die fighting for control of
buckmorton eastern Ukraine has now
lasted for months Kiev says it remains
in control of a key Supply Route into
that City
now our statistics show that when we
have enough Munitions we have ex-people
killed but when we don't have enough
ammunition we have x times five deaths
so this is what I think I'm all but
ready to write up a big report to the
prosecutor General's office or the
investigative committee to look into
this and find and hold those responsible
for the deaths of thousands of Russian
men
let's bring in Pavel falgenhauer he is
an independent Russian defense and
Military analyst he joins us now from
Moscow via Skype Pavel let me start by
asking you is this all just posturing or
might Wagner actually pull out
mostly posturing of course but there's a
serious problems the the Battle of
Bahamut has lasted them
eight months or something and
precaution promised that the city will
be taken it's not been finally taken
it's still divided so there's B right
now everyone there's on the Russian side
there would be
trying to allocate blame who's to blame
so pigon says that he's okay he's Four
soldiers are good but the defense
Ministry is not giving them enough
support that they are the defense
Ministry troops are not fighting as well
and they're not giving them the supplies
and Munitions so it's a kind of the
brain game going on there and a
situation where the Russian winter
offensive is almost over and it achieved
very little on a very high price you say
there's a blame game going on I was
looking at some of the numbers The
Institute for the study of War reports
that pagosian is now saying they've only
received what 800 of the 4 000 shells
per day that they're requesting from the
ministry of Defense that's really quite
the gap
well there's not enough shells that's
quite a problem with the logistical
problem it's a production problem uh the
Russian defense Ministry says that
everyone's given his fair share and that
they cannot take away from other units
so there's again again a brain gain the
main problem is a lack of a battlefield
success and that's really what's fueling
the this exchange of public exchange of
accusations well amidst all of this
though the Wagner Chief progression I
know he doesn't exactly see eye to eye
with the kremlin's commander who is now
running the show how much of the
tensions that we're seeing now is about
that relationship
uh well the precaution says that he is
totally loyal to President Putin that
he's his man and he have known each
other since Saint Petersburg when uh
person weren't in the mayor's office
there in the 90s uh but he has been very
critical precaution about the defense
Ministry uh it's the defense minister
Sergey shoigu his number two general
Valerie gerasim of the chief of general
staff so that's where he has been
already very critical of their actions
and is continuing to be very critical oh
Wagner I know has also been saying
they're loading what seems like
thousands of bodies now into trucks a
day how critical have the Wagner
Fighters been to the fight in bakmud
specifically
well they have been hiring they were
being really critical because uh the
Wagner
mercenaries or volunteers uh you can
call them have been the storm troops
that were thrown into this battle to
dislodge the ukrainians out of this
Morris Fortress City and they were
taking the brunt of the hand-to-hand
Close Quarters fighting and incurring
heavy losses without them this pitched
battle good Hardware could have
continued uh so long and with such a
devastating effect on the city and on
both sides because they're having losses
but the ukrainians are also having heavy
losses this is a very bloody pitched
battle and the Wagner true troops or
mercenaries are apparently more higher
motive invaded it's one of many of them
are criminals who were promised a pardon
and taken a for their fighting so they
have been fighting this battle they have
had some successes in the areas
surrounding but cannot take the final we
take the city still well we'll see if
progression in the meantime makes good
on his threat Pablo falconhauer the
Russian defense and Military analyst
speaking to us from Moscow thanks for
joining us again Pavel always great to
get your thoughts on Al Jazeera